[Musique]
on
cinéma saint benoît cadets dit c'est mon
nom je me suis toujours défini comme
cadres associatifs bénévoles du tissu
associatif culturel invite et culturels
tamouls de saint paul de la région ouest
et de la reille sommet passionnés
dévoués et engagé nous sommes ici en ce
site ancestrales et patrimonial ce lieu
de vie de rencontres de transmission des
valeurs et des connaissances
c'est ici que nous nous sommes toujours
donner les moyens de nos actions
associatives culturelles et sociales
telles que celle portée par
l'association tamise
l'association chante si pour
l'association solidarité enfants du
tamil nadu et pas aussi notre média
social du réseau facebook le groupe g
ce sont des outils qui en septembre
multiculturelle nous permet d'exprimer
de vive
de partager et de faire découvrir notre
attachement à une civilisation
multimillénaire l'hindouisme la fierté
d'un an de ville le zoo fort réunionnais
passionné par cette reconnaissance de
l'héritage indien constitutive du
patrimoine culturel insulaire des
activités culturelles ludiques
pédagogiques d'éducation et de loisirs
avec la promotion la diffusion la
communication et l'information qui s'y
rattachent
afin de maintenir en vie un circuit des
changes permettant la constitution aux
générations futures de fragments
d'identité de connaissances qui
assureront la fonte unité entre le passé
et l'avenir
c'est dans un jeu équipe
on arrive à percer brisé à matrice
d'actions je suis tout mois en mois
d'audiences tradition je me suis
toujours entrevue je fais collégialement
les d'argent il faut savoir que nous
sommes tous les enfants de la
départementalisation
il ya eu beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
d'avancé de progrès considérables dans
le social dans l'éducation dans la santé
dans le développement économique
et forcément ça du tout avoir tout un d
influence positive sur le développement
culturel
deux des composantes techniques
[Musique]